dans les années 80 et 90 des compagnies
de biotechnologies dont monsanto ont
développé une hormone de croissance
synthétique pour augmenter la production
laitière des vaches un produit autorisé
chez nos voisins du sud mais pas ici au
canada
[Musique]
tran
non
aux états unis on vient de donner le feu
vert à la commercialisation d'une
véritable potion magique qui pourrait
accroître jusqu'à 20% et d'un seul coup
la production des meilleure laitière
cette drogue miraculeuse n'est pourtant
qu'une simple hormones de croissance
produite naturellement par l'hypophyse
de tous les mammifères la somat autres
piles celle des bovins comme toutes les
autres est transformé en protéines puis
digérer mais les gains de productivité
venaient avec des inconvénients cinq ans
et quelques études plus tard le canada
rendait son verdict janvier 1999
santé canada refuse le mot location de
la somatropine la santé humaine n'est
pas en cause les experts canadiens
craignent plutôt pour la santé des
vaches laitières l' usage de la somaco
drop in augmente de 25 % les risques de
mammites les vaches traité à cette
hormone ont 50% plus de risques de
souffrir de claudication l'injection de
la somatropine réduire est aussi
l'espérance de vie des vaches laitières
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la somme est autre fils est
toujours autorisé aux états unis
[Musique]
l'enjeu a d'ailleurs refait surface lors
du renouvellement de l'entente de
libre-échange entre le canada les états
unis et le mexique
cette entente est entrée en vigueur en
juillet dernier et elle élargit l'accès
au marché canadien pour les produits
laitiers américain des produits laitiers
qui peuvent contenir cette hormone
interdite au canada
et comme il n'existe aucune règle sur
l'étiquetage de la somme et autres opine
le logo de la vache bleue qui indique
qu'un produit est fabriqué à 100 % à
partir de l'est canadien est le seul
moyen pour les consommateurs de faire un
choix éclairé
[Musique]